Given that encryption or
cryptography in general, plays such
an essential role in security, we can
only expect that attackers will always
try to break an encryption scheme.
Typically, the goal of such
an attack is to uncover
the plaintext from the ciphertext or
to discover the encryption key.
For example, an attacker may
try to recover the plaintext
from the ciphertext that is
transmitted on the Internet.
And you may ask,
how can the attacker obtain such
ciphertext that's
transmitted on the Internet?
The answer is, actually this is
very feasible because an attacker
can use a packet capturing tool
to capture the traffic, and
then extract the ciphertext
in the traffic.
And then from there,
the attacker can attempt to recover the
plaintext from the captured ciphertext.
So as a rule of thumb,
we should always assume that
the ciphertext that we transmit over the
Internet can be captured by an attacker.
Alternatively, the attacker may try
to discover the encryption key, so
that he can then decrypt all
the data encrypted using this key.
That are several attack methods.
The first simplest and yet
the most inefficient way is to use
brute-force, or to search blindly.
For example, an attacker can try
all possible keys, one by one,
until the one that can decrypt
the ciphertext properly into plaintext.
And you may ask, how does the attacker
know that the decryption with a key
has worked properly?
Typically, the attacker knows what
the plaintext should look like.
For example, if the plaintext is an
English sentence, then only the correct
key can decrypt the ciphertext into
data that can be read as English.
This method is very inefficient because
the number of possible keys can be huge,
and so brute-force or search blindly
can take a long time to succeed.
Another approach is
to use cryptanalysis.
Here, a attacker has some knowledge
of the encryption algorithm and
perhaps the characteristics of data,
such as,
distribution of certain letters or
words.
With such knowledge,
the attacker can do a lot better
than using brute-force to
search the entire key space.
Attackers can also exploit
implementation or system's issues.
For example, it was shown that by
using side channel analysis, for
example, by observing the power
consumption used by a crypto system,
an attacker can deduce values of
certain bits of key, and therefore
the attacker can significantly decrease
the key space that he needs to search.
Finally, let's not forget that
the weakest link in security
is the naive users.
And they can be exploited using
social engineering tricks.
For example, an attacker can pretend
to be a sysadmin who has just forgotten
the key, and he called an unsuspected
user for the encryption key to a system.